[SPEAKER_01]: Second of Wealsun.
[SPEAKER_05]: Approaching.
[SPEAKER_05]: Good night.
[SPEAKER_05]: I can take my Homoculi.
[SPEAKER_05]: If you just want to go out there, like you and two other people, and then drop it, and then we can run back to the barracks, and then I can see...
[SPEAKER_06]: What is this word you keep using?
[SPEAKER_06]: Homoculi.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, so I pull out my homoculi, and it looks like this little lizard.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's about that big, that long.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's made of clay.
[SPEAKER_01]: He pulls out this little figurine made of clay.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a lizard!
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh my god, this guy is a kid.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, alright, sure, whatever.
[SPEAKER_05]: And then I climb it up on the wall, and then I glide it to the other wall.
[SPEAKER_05]: And I can see out of it, and I can hear out of it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Think of my toes.
[SPEAKER_01]: So basically, all of you are struck by the witchcraft that Paul Ribeiro is displaying to you.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going to call it witchcraft.
[SPEAKER_00]: I would.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's not.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's definitely witchcraft.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's not, no, a witchcraft.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hey, your witchcraft keeps me alive, I don't care.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just quit while you're alive.
[SPEAKER_05]: All right.
[SPEAKER_05]: But the point is I can see and hear out of this thing.
[SPEAKER_05]: So we can take it with?
[SPEAKER_05]: I can take it with us and we can drop it there and then we can just run back to the barracks and I can see what...
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait, wait, wait.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, but if we have to sneak there, let's just bunker down in the rocks.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you see what you can see.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm throwing an idea.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm just saying, I don't think we want to make that trip twice.
[SPEAKER_02]: Once we start then, you guys guide us in.
[SPEAKER_02]: We can all hunker down in the rocks on the coastline.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you want to send out your winged companion, great.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's awesome.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I don't think we need to go back to the barracks.
[SPEAKER_06]: Does that thing get hurt?
[SPEAKER_06]: It looks like it's clay, so it's not alive.
[SPEAKER_06]: Can you throw it and stick it to a wall or something, or no?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: I mean, okay, it can get hurt and it can die, but I don't take damage and I can't.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, I don't want to kill the thing.
[SPEAKER_06]: I just didn't know what it was.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, you can take it and wing it out there.
[SPEAKER_02]: He can make another one at some time in the future.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't want to.
[SPEAKER_06]: He just has to jack off a little bit.
[SPEAKER_06]: Whoa, whoa.
[SPEAKER_06]: Of course he does.
[SPEAKER_06]: Alright, sounds like it's not too easy to make.
[SPEAKER_05]: No, it was blood.
[SPEAKER_05]: It was blood.
[SPEAKER_05]: I didn't do semen.
[SPEAKER_05]: He didn't even explain that to me until I was reading the book and I asked him to leave.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: He can make another one if it gets crushed.
[SPEAKER_06]: I trust you can help him with that if he needs it.
[SPEAKER_03]: No problem.
[SPEAKER_03]: Here's the plan.
[SPEAKER_03]: We're sending some men out as a distraction over here.
[SPEAKER_03]: We're going to sneak out, go along the coastline, get over here to this corner, and then from there we're going to decide whether we climb the wall or go to... Yeah, we're going to look to see if we can find the cave.
[SPEAKER_06]: If we can find the tunnels quick enough...
[SPEAKER_06]: Easy enough, then that's an option.
[SPEAKER_06]: If there's nothing after searching, and there's too many of those creatures out there, we're going up.
[SPEAKER_00]: Merrick, this is Folsom.
[SPEAKER_02]: What do these guys look like?
[SPEAKER_02]: I know Gouge, I know Paul.
[SPEAKER_03]: They all look like running marines.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm a very, very large man.
[SPEAKER_03]: He's very imposing.
[SPEAKER_00]: He looks like a... How are we going to haul him?
[SPEAKER_01]: A Ridian Marine special.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy is...
[SPEAKER_01]: He's obviously a sailor, but also he's got a little more flair than that and he carries a longbow, which is strange for somebody from the principalities.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy looks like a kid.
[SPEAKER_01]: He actually is a cabin boy.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, not that, but he's basically very handsome.
[SPEAKER_01]: Damn straight.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically, his weaponry does not look like standard marine issue.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, he's wearing the uniform.
[SPEAKER_01]: Everyone's was a ship.
[SPEAKER_02]: Very eclectic group of Marines.
[SPEAKER_02]: I would expect that Gouge wouldn't show up with just your run-of-the-mill standard.
[SPEAKER_02]: In fact, I highly doubt these guys are actually Marines.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I am.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm a Marine, man.
[SPEAKER_02]: I was there.
[SPEAKER_00]: They all have other occupations.
[SPEAKER_04]: I've been serving under Lord Jamis for a long time, and my father was heavily in the Navy, and I worked for the Navy as well through Lord Jamis.
[SPEAKER_04]: Not a Marine, but more of an advisor to captains in the waters around here.
[SPEAKER_06]: Your first impression is tainted by me.
[SPEAKER_06]: It'll go away.
[SPEAKER_02]: I am not, by the way, dressed as a wizard.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm wearing pretty much just straight up like, you know, adventuring clothes, dark colors, just standard stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't have a pointy hat.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't have throwing robes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Got a lot of pouches on me.
[SPEAKER_02]: Got a lot of like, you know, got a dagger at my waist.
[SPEAKER_02]: But other than that, it's pretty standard.
[SPEAKER_02]: Got a hooded cloak.
[SPEAKER_01]: Very underarmored.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: And armed.
[SPEAKER_03]: And how tall are you?
[SPEAKER_03]: You're now?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, so I'm like 5'9", 5'8".
[SPEAKER_03]: You come to my hip.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you're like, what, 6'5"?
[SPEAKER_03]: No, I'm like 6'7".
[SPEAKER_02]: They got a kick in the back?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: He's that Karmirg had bulk.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, plan.
[SPEAKER_03]: Plan is, send some men out, create a diversion.
[SPEAKER_03]: We're gonna, all of us are gonna come up here to this, to the, down in this area over here.
[SPEAKER_04]: We're gonna go, yeah, towards the curse line.
[SPEAKER_04]: Me and Gouge are gonna head out to inspect.
[SPEAKER_04]: Paul can be stealthy.
[SPEAKER_04]: Paul can use his sperm lizard.
[SPEAKER_04]: I do not ever, ever call it a sperm lizard.
[SPEAKER_03]: From this point on, it's sperm lizard.
[SPEAKER_00]: I will write songs about the sperm lizard.
[SPEAKER_00]: I am in use, Brim.
[SPEAKER_00]: You might want to explain what homoculi is and the fact that you didn't use that.
[SPEAKER_02]: We'll do the class and stuff later.
[SPEAKER_02]: Watch out for any patrols of hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_02]: What are these costumes we have?
[SPEAKER_03]: Whatever you say, man.
[SPEAKER_03]: You said we have costumes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Did you want to dress up as the hobgoblins?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh yeah, let me...
[SPEAKER_05]: I have...
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, I don't know if I can help him, but...
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't know any 6'7".
[SPEAKER_02]: We'll have to piece yours together.
[SPEAKER_03]: So should we go that route?
[SPEAKER_02]: Because what I'm worried about is that if we don't dress up and you run into patrols because... Oh, we're dressing up no matter what.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just a second.
[SPEAKER_02]: The captain is not taking that other tower.
[SPEAKER_02]: We don't want to get pinched by patrols when we're trying to sneak up on the main fortress from any coastal foot patrols coming from the other tower.
[SPEAKER_03]: Then what I'm hoping for is that Sahuaglin might see us just as a...
[SPEAKER_02]: If we get too close to the water, right.
[SPEAKER_03]: They might just see us as a hobgoblins as a foot patrol.
[SPEAKER_04]: If we run into any issues, like I said, I can catch.
[SPEAKER_04]: A fog cloud that will get us some time to either get back and levitate it over the wall or a distraction.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I know these coastlines very well.
[SPEAKER_04]: I know how to, you know, some good spots to hide along the coast and stuff.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I think our best option is to move quickly towards those caves.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's my vote.
[SPEAKER_02]: What are you guys okay dressing as in the hub?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, definitely.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm just throwing some stuff over this.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm alright with that.
[SPEAKER_06]: And I'm assuming they're, hey, might even look better.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll throw a helm on, but that's it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so basically what happens is the commander of the barracks at Paul's request brings in some dead hobgoblin robes, helmets, and Paul takes out a cosmetic kit and starts painting your faces red.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically just to, they're very basic disguises, but in the dark you're hoping
[SPEAKER_01]: That that would work.
[SPEAKER_01]: The helmets are right.
[SPEAKER_01]: It just seems to make them look twice.
[SPEAKER_01]: And what's very interesting is the armor that the hobgoblins wear, you're wearing one of their breastplates.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, I'm wearing a breastplate already.
[SPEAKER_01]: The studded leather that they wear is very similar to marine studded leather, and the scale mail is very similar to it as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's just the color's different.
[SPEAKER_04]: We noticed that in the thing, I believe.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly, with the other ones that you encountered.
[SPEAKER_01]: So putting on their cloaks and so on make you look very similar to what
[SPEAKER_01]: They would look like.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I'm hoping this will also help us in the fortress.
[SPEAKER_02]: It might buy us just a little bit of time to either get to jump on somebody, get to pause or hesitate.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, when do you want the commander to attack the front gate?
[SPEAKER_03]: Right now.
[SPEAKER_03]: Let's go.
[SPEAKER_03]: As soon as we're painted.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't want to be in position, or you don't want them to give time to get in position?
[SPEAKER_05]: I think we need to at least be within...
[SPEAKER_02]: It's going to draw all their eyes to the front, so we need to be on their flank.
[SPEAKER_05]: We don't want to be in their line of sight where they're looking and trying to sneak.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't want to be crossing any kind of open terrain.
[SPEAKER_05]: We're going to go out before them at least... Maybe 20, 30 minutes?
[SPEAKER_02]: 30 minutes.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's what I would do it.
[SPEAKER_04]: That gives us time to get to where we need to be.
[SPEAKER_04]: Out of that, so when they start seeing them all coming out.
[SPEAKER_02]: And they're going to make some braziers and some fires.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're going to make a big show of assembling the... Steve, prepare your men to leave in 30 minutes.
[SPEAKER_01]: So attack at 1230?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: And distance-wise, how long are we guessing it might take us here?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, from here to here, it's like maybe 750 feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you can probably get there stealthing within 10 minutes.
[SPEAKER_04]: We need to signal the South Beacon to what we're going to do, roughly, because I don't want them to think that we're under attack and send troops our way.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do it now.
[SPEAKER_04]: Not knowing what we're doing.
[SPEAKER_04]: I can do a signal.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you send a message to the South Beacon, basically saying...
[SPEAKER_01]: Ignore any attack that we make.
[SPEAKER_01]: Everything's fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wait for another signal if needed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wait for a different signal.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then... Let's do it.
[SPEAKER_01]: The six of you move out into the night through the south exit.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean the...
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm sorry, the north exit.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you're going to travel that way up the coast.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, let's move inside so I can see how it's going on.